on veut diminuer notre consommation de
viande rouge j'en veux augmenter notre
apport en légumineuses mais c'est pas
toujours simple l'industrie fait de gros
efforts pour nous aider ici Céline
Galipeau l'assiette des Canadiens se
modernise moins de viande plus de
légumineuses et beaucoup d'eau l'une des
principales recommandations du plus
récent Guide alimentaire canadien et
d’intégrer davantage de légumineuses à
nos menus quotidiens depuis quelques
temps on peut les apprêter sous une
nouvelle forme en parse alimentaire je
pense que tranquillement les gens aiment
découvrir qu'avec les légumineuses il y
a autre chose à faire que la soupe aux
pois ou que les bines de la cabane à
sucre donc c'est avec la nutritionnistes
Stéphanie côté que nous avons analysé et
goûter à ces parts alimentaires toutes
son bio est la plupart sans gluten
spaghetti fusil et même lasagnes l'offre
en épicerie est plutôt vaste je suis
impressionné par la quantité de produits
il y a un grand choix de les
légumineuses et j'ai été très surprise
même épatée par la liste des ingrédients
qui est très souvent tellement simple
que je me demande comment ça tient
parfois c'est la légumineuse et c'est
tout ici il y a des haricots noirs c'est
tout donc c'est vraiment très surprenant
il y a des listes d'ingrédients quelques
produits présentent par contre des
listes d'ingrédients un peu plus longues
farine de quinoa de riz brun ou semoule
de blé ont été ajoutés dans ces cas
qu'est-ce qu'on trouve comme légumineuse
surtout il semble que les pois chiches
reviennent très souvent les lentilles
vertes et on voit aussi également
haricots noirs qui sont les plus
fréquentes est-ce qu'on peut vraiment
faire un comparatif avec les pattes de
blé en termes de protéines ben il y en a
où ça se ressemble mais ça ici ça va du
simple au double
c'est la légumineuse où on retrouve le
plus de protéines et le plus de fibres
alimentaires garde d'ailleurs tu vois 36
g de protéines ça je dirais même que
trop c'est comme passé
notre organisme il y a des études qui
montrent que notre corps va absorber à
peu près 30 g de protéines dans un repas
pour les fibres alimentaires ça va de
trois à 20 g donc c'est un très très
grand écart même chose pour les glucides
ça va du simple au double donc plusieurs
bonnes raisons de d'explorer le monde
des pâtes aux légumineuses beaucoup de
protéines beaucoup de fibres et même de
faire aussi ça c'est intéressant parce
que dans les pattes alimentaires
régulières de blé on est obligé au
Canada les enrichir en certaines
vitamines et en fer
le Canada est un chef de fil mondial de
la production de légumineuses il est le
premier producteur de pois chiches et de
lentilles étonnamment toutes les pattes
d'alimentaire que nous avons trouvées en
épicerie sont fabriqués en Italie ou en
Chine aucune est fabriqué au Canada
c'est un paradoxe le Canada
spécialisée en protéines végétales je
pense que le consommateur canadien n'est
pas habitué à consommer des légumineuses
ne connaît pas le produit ce qui fait
que il y a peu de transformateurs qui
s'essaye de fabriquer des pâtes à partir
de farine de légumineuses peut-être
qu'il y a un savoir-faire qui manque ici
mais ce n'est pas un savoir de faire
difficile à acquérir
les légumineuses ne contiennent pas de
gluten alors que celui-ci joue un rôle
important pour créer la texture des
pattes alimentaires traditionnelles
pour pouvoir faire des pâtes à 100%
légumineuses ça nous prend quelque chose
qui va remplacer ce gluten les
lumineuses elles sont riches en
protéines mais c'est des protéines qui
sont différentes que celles qui existent
dans le blé donc ils n'ont pas cette
capacité justement ses propriétés
viscoélastiques à former cette structure
c'est l'amidon présent dans les
légumineuses qui va lier les pattes cet
amidon doit être gélatinisé en élevant
la température de la farine avec de la
vapeur pour ensuite en produire une pâte
ensuite on le passe dans l'extrudeuse à
pâte conventionnelle comme celle qu'on
utilise pour les pâtes à base de blé et
à qui ça s'adresse c'est pas le peuvent
vraiment servir les personnes qui
veulent éviter le gluten qui ont la
maladie cœliaque par exemple ce sont
aussi des parts généralement qui sont
véganes donc même pas d'oeuf dans la
composition pour des personnes qui sont
diabétiques des pattes à 100%
légumineuses seraient une meilleure
option parce que les légumineuses
justement ont une charge glycémique qui
est moindre pour les personnes qui
hésitent à manger des légumineuses
entières ou qui savent pas comment les
cuisiner je pense que c'est une belle
façon de diversifier de les apprivoiser
[Musique]
ici on a des spaghettis des damamet ici
des spaghettis de haricots noirs des
coquilles de pois chiches et lentilles
et ici des lentilles vertes
[Musique]
la texture
un peu farineuse un peu granuleuse on
goûte la lentille je mettrai une sauce
tomate mais ça pourrait aussi être une
salade de pâtes
[Musique]
le goût du pois chiche le prend vraiment
toute la place la texture tu vois que ça
se défait un tout petit peu les
coquilles sont plus fragiles ça se
défend plus facilement et les pâtes
longues quand on les cuit là on voit
leur fragilité quand l'eau bout puis
qu'on met notre poignée de pâtes dans
l'eau bouillante on voit que c'est très
très friable il est pas bon presque
casser dans nos mains ça cuit à peu près
3 minutes et une fois qu'elles sont
cuites les pâtes elles se tiennent
vraiment très bien la sauce adhère aussi
aux pâtes durant la cuisson l'eau
devient un petit peu visqueuse ce qui
est tout à fait normal la texture de
celle-ci est très intéressante je trouve
c'est celle qui sous la dent est
agréable il y a un petit côté
caoutchouceux
les pattes longues l'emporte sur les
bords le prix des pâtes de légumineuses
aussi entre deux et quatre dollars par
100 g c'est sûr que c'est plus cher que
les pâtes de blé mais il faut peut-être
pas les voir comme un substitut au parc
de blé on peut les voir comme un
substitut à la viande dans ce cas là ça
nous peut-être un petit peu moins payer
ce prix là c'est souvent des produits
qu'on va retrouver dans des rayons sont
pour les produits sans gluten mais moi
je pense qu'on gagnerait à les exposer
un peu plus j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir
aussi ce qu'on aime beaucoup c'est à
dire le Macario fromage et je dirais
plus le macaroni au fromage d'ailleurs
et le test ultime
c'est pas un copier-coller non non
espérer tromper personne avec ça mais
on a l'impression de manger santé
[Musique]